new this afternoon three las vegas  supermarkets are being sued for  allegedly selling tainted baby food  the lawsuit was filed on behalf of six  families and seven children  the lawsuit claims baby food with high  levels of arsenic lead and mercury  can cause autism marianas la bonita  supermarkets and meat market are named  in the case  all three are owned by the same company  attorneys also sued some food makers  including gerbers and beechnut  for making the food well they have an  automatic responsibility on a nevada law  as a distributor of a defective product  whether they knew  or did not know it was defected  defective  it may be that the baby food companies  tricked them too and thought  and they thought they were selling safe  product that may be the case  but under nevada law they're still  liable families are seeking medical and  compensatory damages we have reached out  to marianas and lamodita supermarkets  we have not yet heard back